un gouvernement d'unité qui va de la
gauche aux populistes de la droite dure
la nouvelle équipe multicolores de mario
draghi composé de 23 ministre a obtenu
la confiance du sénat et du parlement
sous les applaudissements pour super
mario comme on le surnomme c'est un
plébiscite
mais l'homme providentiel doit relever
un vaste défi reconstruire un pays
durement frappé par la crise économique
et sanitaire
un programme qui nécessite un
gouvernement soudé aujourd'hui l'unité
n'est pas une option c'est un devoir
mais c'est un devoir guide et j'en suis
certain par ce qui nous unit tous
l'amour pour l'italie une lune de miel
politique saluée par la plupart des
forces partisanes
enfin presque l'irréductible matteo
salvini qui n'a pas été retenu dans
l'équipe gouvernementale ne cesse de
prendre à partie les ministres et de
multiplier les provocations à l'encontre
du nouveau président du conseil bras guy
dit que l'euro est irréversible fort
heureusement il n'y a que la mort
d'irréversible la seule chose pour
laquelle il n'y a pas de remède c'est la
volonté du bon dieu
quant au mouvement 5 étoiles ils
s'estiment mal servi dans le nouveau
gouvernement et menace d'imploser qu'un
sénateur de la formation fondée par
beppe grillo se sont prononcés contre le
gouvernement draghi tandis que huit
autres ne se sont pas déplacés pour le
vote de confiance
si la majorité de la presse transalpine
accueille l'arrivée de l'ex président de
la bce avec enthousiasme certains ne
manquent pas de rappeler le passé très
libérale de l'économiste voilà
qu'aujourd'hui on ressuscite le mythe
d'un draghi keynésien capable d'impulser
une phase d'expansion des dépenses
sociales mais personne ne croit à cette
illusion pieuse
le problème est qu un gouvernement non
élu qui n'a donc que faire de la
recherche du consensus démocratique a
les mains libres pour mettre en oeuvre
un bain de sang social
en effet mario draghi a été le fer de
lance du processus de privatisation des
biens publics lorsqu'il dirigeait le
trésor de 1991 à 2001 privatisation de
plus de 700 entreprises
réduction drastique des dépenses
publiques et mesures attendues pour
redresser la péninsule risque de ne pas
faire l'unanimité
la dolce vita attendra